Nature loves balance.
Ever sprinkle salt on a piece of eggplant?
Over time, the eggplant starts to sweat out water.
This happens because there is a different ratio
of salt to water on the surface versus
inside the eggplant, so water seeps out
onto the surface to try and equalize how salty
the water is inside and out.
This balancing act is called osmosis.
It happens throughout nature –
even in massive bodies of water –
like where rivers meet the sea.
Scientists have been trying to harness the power
of this balancing act --called blue energy
by sticking thin membranes in between
sea water and fresh water.
The holes in the membranes are too small
to allow water to move through, like in the eggplant,
so instead, the charged particles from the salt move.
This flow of charged particles can be
harnessed to create electricity.
In order for the charges to continue flowing,
the membrane needs to be selective—
meaning it should only let
one type of ion through.
Since manufacturing the membranes
relies on nanotechnology,
it is often expensive to build and maintain them,
and the system can lose efficiency over time.
It’s a challenge to scale up these systems
to produce enough power to make them worth the cost.
Now, scientists have built a 3-d Janus membrane
named after the mythical god with two faces.
The Janus membrane has different properties
on each side, which makes it a good gatekeeper
for encouraging a steady flow of charged particles
from one side to the other.
The membrane can be tuned to have different
sized pores and accept different kinds of
charged particles.
The researchers measured how efficient this process
was at converting chemical energy to electrical energy.
At about 35.7 percent it’s better than a solar cell
but not as good as a wind turbine.
The team hopes that Janus membranes can be
used to create more efficient and less expensive
blue energy generators.
These systems can be deployed to generate power
in coastal communities that don’t have large enough
waterfalls or strong enough currents
for other forms of water power -
like underwater turbines.
In order to find new forms of renewable energy
and limit carbon emissions,
researchers are looking in unexpected places -
even tapping into salty solutions.